[Musique]
en ile-de-france les chiffres ne cessent
de s'accroître
on y recense en moyenne 404 nouvelles
contaminations pour 100000 habitants
trois départements sont particulièrement
inquiétants la seine-saint-denis le
val-de-marne et le val-d'oise
le taux d'incidence y est supérieur au
pas de calais ou en confinement le week
end est déjà en vigueur
elle a posté sur ces réseaux cette photo
que vous allez voir
voilà en janvier dernier vacciner
heureuse un grand sourire sort qu'elle
est quand même suivi par plus de cent
mille personnes sur instagram
il n'en fallait pas plus pour faire le
buzz sur sondages évidemment son âge qui
est évidemment secret elle n'a l'a
jamais révélé on s'est dit forcément les
plus de 75 ans et oui c'est moi de le
tirer et non elle est l effet partie des
personnes prioritaires parce que ça vous
semble le bon moment pour relancer cette
réforme des retraites alors nous surtout
on prend soin de ne jamais répondre à ce
type de question il n'ya plus débat mais
évidemment les gens ne sachant pas ça on
dit ah bah oui voilà je vous l'avais
bien dit à 95 ans 108 en jeu
ça m'est totalement égal mais totalement
égal ça fait des années que je ne
souffle plus les bougies de son temps et
coûte plus cher que le gâteau donc c'est
fini
là je ne m'intéresse pas du tout vous
êtes déjà vu dans l'émission on avait
déjà pas évoquer votre métier de
projectionniste très exactement
d'accord ça fait combien de temps vous
êtes passé ça fait quatre ans quatre ans
90 s'est passé dans votre vie de nouveau
de différent
il ya eu un confinement c'est pas vrai
deux ratés trop difficile pour s'éclater
en franchise alors je sais pas ce qui m
dans ce vaccin mais je vous dis ça vous
donne une pêche dans ce sais pas si ça
doit vitamines dans ses arrières en tout
cas moi ça m'a filé une pêche ce vaccin
pouvait pas savoir alors pour ça j'ai
dit à tout le monde vaccinez vous
accédez fantasy quand on dirait on
dirait les vieilles locomotives quand
elle démarre vous savez il est
magnifique il accélère maintenant
mesdames et messieurs c'était il va se
faire écraser attention à les retrouver
en direct sur rtl
ici c'est un nouveau variant qui fait
l'objet de toutes les attentions des
autorités de santé
cette mutation est apparu dans l'hôpital
de lannion dans les côtes d'armor le 13
mars 79,4 coronavirus ils ont été
identifiés dont huit porteurs de ce
variant une évaluation est en cours pour
connaître son impact
mais les premiers résultats sont
rassurants et alors le variant breton
c'est celui qui a un petit nuage
pluvieux au dessus de la tête parce
qu'on rappelle qu'en bretagne alors on
peut dire parfois qu'il fait beau
plusieurs fois par jour on dit aussi
qu'il pleut pas ou feint qui pleut que
ne peut pas sur tout le monde voit la
petite renarde breton soit un spécial
sur bfm tv on embraye
[Musique]
je te le dis tu prends sa veste
c'est terminé tu prends sa veste regarde
moi bien j'ai une parole tu prends sa
veste c'est terminé abbas a déjà
commencé tu veux prendre ça commence
chez ma tante agace tout le monde
chris je te donne mon coeur mon coeur je
donne à personne d'accord mon coeur j'ai
donné à personne
j'ai failli faire confiance à une meuf
qui quoi qui prend une baisse au premier
venu ballot mais toi tes clips et est
donc éclipsé les ans quelques manants
carte sa bête c'est regarde moi bien oui
on voit bien que tout le monde soit
témoin que tout le monde soit témoin
mais c'est la dernière fois que je parle
avec moi c'est bon je n'ai pas envie de
répondre à madame bachelot ni aux chiens
de garde de du gouvernement parce que je
ne les écoute pas par principe je
n'écoute pas j'imagine que ça devait pas
être très gentil
ce qui est dommage c'est que le
répugnant de le dire puisque elle était
dans la salle au début semble-t-il elle
s'est barrée
donc s'il a des choses à dire l ai dit
en face déjà et d'une et si quand elle
se pointe comme l'a fait chez les
camarades de l'odéon si c'est juste pour
faire semblant de gratter de prendre des
questions et ne répondre les paroles on
s'en fout elle est venue avant la
représentation elle nous a salués et je
lui ai dit la même chose d'ailleurs je
suis dit hé ros il faut peut-être que
fois peut-être quand même se battre un
peu plus pour nous et elle m'a dit j'y
travaille jour et nuit donc au met en
avant d'essayer d'inventer une nouvelle
façon de
de constituer c'est à dire que on veut
pas récurrentes comme moi je ne veux pas
récupéré le monde je veux un nouveau
monde
les prix
oui j'en ai pas vraiment j'en ai marre
j'en ai marre parce que je je il n'ya il
n'y a vraiment aucune raison de laisser
la culture comme ça il y en a il n'y a
pas de raison de donner sa démission
comme l'a fait hulot je pense pas
qu'elle aura ce courage là et vous
voudriez vous pensez qu'il faudrait
creuser une bachelot donne sa démission
je verse mais je crois pas qu'un autre
fera mieux ce polonais de 50 ans est la
risée des médias dans son pays avec ce
triste record 192 échec consécutive
consécutif à l'examen du code de la
route sans véritable explication à le
code de la route n'est pas plus complexe
en pologne qu'ailleurs et l'école de
conduite qu'il fréquente affiche un taux
de réussite de 70 % à l'examen bon taux
qui va forcément des cendres bref il a
toutes les cartes en main a priori pour
que la 193e tentatives soit la bonne et
puis ensuite faudra s'atteler à la
pratique
isabelle mois pour un noël il m'a offert
un rétroviseur de voitures a beau paquet
cadeau et l'aider et aussi non c'est pas
possible c'est pas nous faire cinq
heures de route pour un resto que
d'ailleurs c'était pas de but où
landreau mairie
[Musique]
la complexité
moi j'avais orgie ailleurs peut aller
oui ça marche aussi ça ne rentrait pas
ici on aurait dit ça rentre toujours tu
as des complexes et un des choses
complexes c'est l'enjeu sas a flétri
c'est comme les fruits d'un jour et un
collègue qui me regardent médias quand
je regarde ta bouche mondiale est
introduit
mais ça m'a scotché au uk jonathan boit
un verre et un verre à peu dans l'autre
il boit un verre deux verres trois
verres et même calvaire
et là je me dis mais on est dans une
zone normalement et le partage j'étais
dans le partage mais qui était bourré tu
étais pas du tout
ah oui